hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to massive loathing is
what it's actually called not something
else I was gonna say and I don't know
what that is but either way we got done
with the bureaucratic nightmare that's
there but we still don't have a logging
permit for it because we need to wait
two days for that but I don't have two
days to wait I need to go and get this
train done did but before I do that I
gotta find me a girder my horn Swabia
Agger stern teddy bear or something of
the like and I remember the the skeleton
that I ran into in this hill over here
and also that lady maybe you have
something in there I don't know idea but
I didn't tell this Skellington number
one that he was those Gallatin or number
two that are the cultists are dead from
another skeleton hello who are you
wait I already know this but I took care
of them already I don't you remember
this okay I took care of them oh great
whoo that's a load off my mind let me
tell you here you can have this worry
stone I don't need it now this rock has
had a hole rubbed in it by incessant
whirring fidgeting with it will stop you
from looking so anxious all the time
this goes in your offhand AHA an Old
West fidget spinner huh very nice
got some good Moxie on that one but I
don't know if I want to replace my
sweet-smelling flowers actually I
absolutely want to do that I don't know
I've had that still there I'm gonna put
my worry stone said I don't always be
spinning my fidgety all the way wherever
I'm going but there's got to be
something else here that I'm missing
there's still the thing in the lost
Dutch oven month the circus what better
place to find a teddy bear they got a
circus can I go in the goddamn tent now
what have I not done this did I not do
this I'd like to see I'd like to run
away with you I'd like to see it then
please have I not oh that's right
okay I get I remember I forgot about it
that uh that I didn't I didn't redo the
circus spit on my playthrough so I'll be
right back Oh frabjous day
Callooh Callay oh my gosh I've got a
large brush owl yeah I got that okay so
what I did was I actually did I already
got the tickets AWS is doing all these
cuz my stats are so high by now so I'm
just gonna do this and I'm gonna what
surprise do literally data to do the
shoot like a Jaguar
that's super neat okay but now I've got
two large plushies and I don't need one
of them and I can carry my cat with me
can I get a little fluffy one
what is this goddamn mainstage gonna be
open show until later oh my god of
course it's later when the hell does
that happen
it doesn't nothing this is nothing
Barnaby bob is a sham and a liar but now
I have everything I need for Frisco for
Frisco Oh defend myself I don't know
what's happening but I'll defend myself
how about this bang bang bang oh well
that did not work out for you either way
I got plugs aminal so now I can take my
plushed a bundle on to this trade walk
over the way over dere here go through
here back up here go over yonder way as
I explain everything that I'm doing in
excruciating detail you know like a
let's player wood and okay these people
here got you on board you're on board
you and Russell are on board Russell
Crowe by the way Russell the crow
Russell Crowe anyway alright hello how
about this plush out wool wow she's
great she takes the owl and gives it a
big hug okay mister say the word and
we'll show that jerk what for alright
it's
we time for this we're gonna confront
you Norton
I'm uninstalling oh I only needed three
ah you pound on the door to the
locomotive our engine car cab or
whatever
open up Norton no alright then I'm
coming in oh yeah you and what army
tough guy me in this army you and the
passengers break down the door very
impressively though it would have been
even better if you had some torches in
those old-fashioned rakes Norton has
backed up into the corner of the
engineers compartment next to the
engineer who looks over his shoulder at
you and shrugs so-called Emperor Norton
you're under arrest for the crime of
being a total ass that's not illegal it
is when I'm in town pachow put ciao ciao
ciao ciao
oh we're there so is it that I shot him
up real good like right actually if you
could turn around and head back to
Frisco at the next station that'd be
great
oh wait it is everyone grab him except
you mr. engineer we're I can see we're
busy driving the drain right turn back
to Frisco no problem oh ow let go this
isn't over
you haven't heard the last of me tell it
to the judge Norton the prison ha got
him got him good got him good we made it
Oh fan twit what do you say about
popping okay you did it
thanks boss no problem we got the track
laid right up to the station now I know
this wasn't my voice before but you can
ignore that the first half of cross
territory railroad thanks to the
manifest destiny
d destiny our railroad cou company
company and principaling you you did a
real good job mum Fleur thumper dink
aw shucks don't mention it and call me
boss please you really should okay oh oh
my goodness oh my goodness
this is a one-way train why they build a
one-way train can't they just pick it up
and turn it around and then it'd be a
two-way train all right whatever I guess
it can only go forward so looks like
somebody on that train got the job as a
projectionist would you like to watch
this movie it's free because movies have
only recently been invented nobody's
figured out that you they can charge
for them yet no doing this will not
change anything about the world of your
character when the cutscene is over
you'll still be right here and you can
keep playing if you want
show me the final cutscene that's the
[Music]
excuse you well I'll be a new face I'm
Clun include salute see make yourself at
home
thanks I'm mum Fleur fum / ting new to
town I've been helping manifest destiny
get the rail tracks laid it was a tough
job but we finally got here sounds like
you could use a drink clean sea I sure
could what have you got oh I'll take
this Olive gin cone sure whatever that
means
all right got back oh boy another
spittoon let's go what's with these I've
given up this is the last petunia in the
game and I'm not gonna try and convince
you to not be the most disgusting person
on earth anymore
let's go let's do this put if I back
away slowly slowly ah boring alright
yeah search that filthy spittoon you
kneel down on the floor and throw your
arms around the spittoon giving the
greasy brass bucket a great big hug how
about a kiss would you like to kiss it
you know it baby you pucker up
and give this patoot a great big kiss
right on the rim is there tongue I'll
leave it up to you but even without it
it tastes like a burning a horse I love
it I know he's different and if it were
legal in this country that spittoon and
have a beautiful romantic night with it
but unfortunately you're going to have
to settle for wearing it as a yes
[Music]
drenching yourself in hot Brown tobacco
spit it washes down over your face in
here like a sewage waterfall soaking
your clothes running down your collar
and slithering into your underwear and
filling your boots
I can't even force myself to describe it
in any more detail than that you are the
world's most foul list human being
congratulations
[Music]
which is to say it's a spittoon that you
have turned upside down and placed on
top of your head oh I wish I was a bean
slinger
I really wish oh look I wish it said
Spit upside down on it I'm gonna put a
snakeskin on it do I have any more
rainbow snake skins SiC Python oh this
skin was until very recently stretched
taut around some giant pulsating big
muscles it's gross to think about and to
look at but I get 30 HP for it that's
pretty dang good oh apply to my hat blam
you stretched the Python skin around
your hat your hat immediately gets more
muscular and veiny
oh my spit the veins are pumping sweet
tobacco spit around it for circulation
ah
that's terrible oh hello what's all this
then it's a real Frisco fracas all right
sure we got the jump on them this time
why do I want to kill these guys I don't
know if I do but here I go I guess bang
bang bang
well they're dead now you emerged from
the brawl relatively unscathed all right
goodbye then I don't feel like murdering
anybody else
sorry no darts management known as dirts
oh my god it drips of course it drips
it's pulsating with veins it's got a
drip
it's a flutter of sorry I can't read it
seems oddly smudged with water damage or
what I can only assume is water damage
you got a comedy flyer this is something
you found on the ground in Frisco which
means that in the absolute best case
scenario it's garbage well time to look
at that garbage read it read the garbage
it turns out to be a flyer for a comedy
shack up north of Frisco you jot down
the location on your map and throw the
flyer away you discover a new map
location Roscoe's comedy Shack okay
all right then hello hello ding-dong
Bing bong it's just nearly identical
houses as far as the eye can see in that
direction
oh but gluten sees it can't be over I
gotta go to the comedy Shack I'll see
the it said I could play the game after
this final cutscene but uh I'll get that
at the end of the episode I want to see
what's up with Wasco is comedy shack
guys with a name like Wasco you can't be
Wong F all right Oh
watering Sally I was wondering where you
were wandering a hello hey Gary
oh hey ha I think this is where living a
crazy squirrel man's a what now
crazy squirrel man's you seeing you
discovered a new map location Holloway's
hideout okay all right what do you think
we should do next
Wow the day you saving it shucks I
couldn't have done it without you Gary
come on let's go to the final gutsy sure
hoping having a happy ending Gary loves
happy ending whoa the suit guys are what
do you got I don't
I need that fungicide well if I was I'm
gonna buy that because there's a
possibility it's the possibility all
right anyway
so there's a possibility that you
remember that Shack in that thing with
I'm dripping sorry Sally you've seen me
in better days but uh you know today is
not that day but there was a Shack that
had all the goblins that were exploding
in it your booze senses tingles you
spurt Imbler towards the source of the
disturbance in the liquor sphere and
find a little still hidden in the pines
you discover moonshine still I'm gonna
go to Moscow comedy Shack where comedy
can't go wrong hey Gary what are
cobbling jokes like do you know any good
ones oh knowing very funny joke a goblin
to entering human bar and human
bartender to saying hello
we do not serve a goblin and the Goblin
saying of course not you are full of
juice is very funny pun probably not
translating very well not so much no not
at all Bosco's comedy shack funny ha ha
yuk yuk joke jokes oh my all right
nice hat I'm glad we could meet on this
such a prestigious day Oh howdy howdy
howdy
whoa ah skosh afters a name and comedies
again I'd like to think this guy has my
voice you know the voice of someone who
thinks he's funnier than he actually is
we're here for a real thigh slapping
good time it's me markiplier ah alright
hit me
yeah and over the meat and Wasco clears
his throat ok so a skeleton walks into a
bar and the bartender says wait it's a
horse not a skeleton sorry anyway after
the bartender asked the horse hey why is
your face so long buddy
seriously Wasco takes about I wanna hear
another word I sure do already guy walks
into a bar and the bartender says sorry
we don't serve goblins here oh yeah I
forgot to mention the guy's goblin
anyway I'm
the end whoo oh boy okay here's a good
one take my wife please please that's it
hit me anyway I just flew in from
Canadia which is weird right because
people can't fly except for in balloons
or gliders I guess we don't have actual
airplanes for at least another couple of
decades anyway okay hit me guy walks
into a bar he asks for a beer and a mop
bartender says what's them up for got
replies because I'm a skeleton
oh come on Wasco Wasco you're real bad
it is not you're bad at the stuff you do
dumb things probably I shoot people want
to test that theory come on let me tell
you another one all right hit me nope
don't like dowan your Z aren't good at
comedy shut up I'm great at jokes no you
aren't what about my your timing is
terrible timing
I'm telling you sincerely you should
quit well that's that's pretty direct
but I gotta be honest man alright
alright fine I admit it can't tell jokes
worth a darn
and my name is ah Wasco its markiplier
what else am I gonna do you're pretty
decent banjo player the jewel and dirt
water could use a banjo
oh that sounds pretty good can't be much
worse okay bye
did I do a celebratory flip can I go in
the shack
alright then well he's now there now and
that's great I'm gonna go to the
moonshine still and see what that's
about
I'm gonna defend myself apparently Shaw
bang bang bang hurry you're dead now
things seem a lot easier now that I can
shoot things real hard also I haven't
taken care of the necromancer
this is Jarrah moonshine under the spout
I got a German shine all right then why
did I get a jar of moonshine I think I
stole this you drink the moonshine then
how old with the empty jar that
moonshine you drank represents
everything that's bad about alcohol and
equal measure it's a good thing you're
drunk or you might be moved to take up
temperance a whoo Oh whoo whoo whoo
all right well did that that's great
ah yes a still fer to stealin dis silly
but yeah good I although it's a little
more complicated than looking at one my
own class also differing from cactus
still alright well I used it so I guess
I'm done
requires me requires moon yes
bits of moon what does that mean
Holloway do you know Oh
mining are maybe first aid supplies
alright whatever
whoa hey that's a lot of stuff I got a
cage canary it's hard to be scared of
anything with this little guy always
chirping a cheerful tune oh oh that's
nice a medical gun if you don't think
about it too much a pistol is just a
more effective I'm not gonna think about
that too much because it makes sense
immediately I don't even need to think
about it this blood splatter is
disturbingly squirrel [ __ ] your partner
yes here being a crazy squirrel man's it
doesn't seem to be a lot of squirrels
around here he is a squirrel shop you
mean he sells squirrels what for no
selling to squirrels
okay hello this barrel used to have
pickles in it now it's just nasty old
pickle juice okay howdy names Holloway
hab Holloway king of the squirrels sorry
for the chittering I ain't seen another
person in a long time it's not
surprising this place is pretty secluded
what do you do out here
mostly I sell pine cones to squirrels he
frowns well I used to huh all right you
choose on something I had stored away in
one of his cheeks what happened in the
squirrels but one day they were here the
next there were bloodstains
I had the creepiest dream that night I
dreamt a little girl with a big empty
wide eyes jumped in through my bedroom
window and asked me if I wanted to have
tea party let's talk about something
else all the way I found this silver pin
oh dang it
what oh I had a pen
I was hoping not to see that again I
locked it up with the keys inside on
purpose too many bad memories appreciate
them intention mr. O'Connor you but go
ahead and keep it is there something to
do with why you live all the way out
here with the squirrels I just don't
feel comfortable in regular society no
more is it something to do with this old
pickaxe I think he's a a where squirrel
I'm pretty sure this guy is a where
squirrel you know like a werewolf but a
where squirrel I'm a Cod no I didn't do
nothin he starts chattering wildly and
squirrel whoa whoa whoa easy there calm
down man putting it away and never mind
he grabbed the howl the way grabs a
paper bag from under the counter and
hyperventilates into it for a bit
eventually he calms down though he still
is kind of a wild look in his eye so
welcome to my shop glad you're free let
me see what you're selling it so I'm
pretty sure I'm gonna buy one of these
because I haven't seen one of these
anywhere clip-on bow tie you would never
wear this but maybe you'll find a child
that needs help break for a funeral
oh that valise sounds oh all right fine
I'll buy it jar peanut butter can I rub
it on the face can I rub the peanut
butter on my face can I rub a peanut
butter on my face can I rub the peanut
butter on my face and call myself the
king of the squirrels gonna do that
do that by these thank you anyway
won't pry further so there's something
about Holloway here in that silver pin
maybe you was in that mauve madness mind
you know the lost Dutch oven mine and
that's what that's all about but I think
I'm getting close to the end of this
episode and I just want to see what this
guy can do with this this jewelry have a
look oh ah I need to get some meat I
need to sell some stuff before I'm able
to do that but there wasn't a shop in
Frisco maybe there was maybe it's shelf
stuff at any shop and I don't know I'll
be right back okay I'm back now I have
meat you want some meat I've got plenty
of meat here's a strange silvery crystal
you got a silicon ring cannot be feeling
this ring is a waste of whatever that
silver crystal was but on the other hand
it is a very nice ring how about the
unbreakable Ruby master Gerald takes
your unbreakable Ruby cuts and polishes
it and sets a fine ring unbreakable ruby
ring
this circle shall remain unbroken
actually the circle is the weak part
it's the gem that won't break well great
good for me okay there's no point to any
of that okay so I a back to Frisco it is
so I'm gonna see this final cutscene
right after I Hornswoggle this whatever
I got a muck clogged blunderbuss wait
okay
wow you haven't been taking very good
care of that gun what were you half
buried on the ocean floor for like 40
years
yes oh really huh well anyway that's
prob that thing's probably just gonna
explode if you try to fire it let me
have a look I can probably tune it up
for you the skeleton hands over his gun
and you inspect it carefully and then
use it to blow his skull clean off okay
no my mistake it's a bit mucky but it's
basically fine that's a nice gun a muck
clogged good nervous I'd like to think
that the muck adds a little extra Moxie
onto it is that better than my befoul
pistol well I mean I gotta admit going
from a beef fowl do a muck clogged you
know the spittoon hat does abide such
trends
aggression so I think that we can all
forgive each other as I travel muck all
the way back to the movie theater so
here we go
some folks say endings don't matter but
other folks they like to know how things
turn out the consequences of their
actions like with the trains running
again Frisco thrived people came from
all over to seek their fortunes but
thanks to you they didn't have to do it
while on fire because some cow attacked
their wagon Oh press any key to continue
look at all these people that are
moderately not happy but you know
they're okay they're living life out in
the wood that guy's asleep but whatever
ah look at all these identical houses
that they wouldn't let me see but I'm
kind of curious to see what's at the end
of the row if if anything all right all
the people that were in the game oh
you're gonna call me boss okay bye then
all right look at all these people look
at all their hats look at that
drugged-out guy oh that's so nice
with the railroad completed in Norton
out stood Smee found himself out of a
job but with an opportunity after being
elected mayor he managed the growth and
infrastructure of Frisco with compassion
and pragmatism in 1944 Frisco was named
most reasonable city by the Tuesday
Tuesday evening post that's nice
that's real nice well that's I'll look
your mayor
you still need to call me boss or kind
of I'm sorry I guess after you got
settled in Gary climbed at the top of
the tallest building in Frisco and shot
spores every whichaway
pose they say is descendants still roam
west to the snow
that's a lot of Gary's that's a lot of
Gary's gross gross
thanks to your assistance Hobart bumper
got the photography bug or should we say
the photography owl anyway he opened an
art gallery so the citizens of Frisco
would never have to suffer from the
inability to see pictures of an Alice
killed since whenever they wanted oh no
we know I'm not done you said it
wouldn't change anything about the war
our old curse left the fort to set up
shop in Frisco his column fitness group
skyrocketed in popularity the gross was
entirely due to word-of-mouth because
the first rule of Kurtz fit is that you
cannot stop talking about Kurtz Fett
Kurtz till it hurts for everybody no you
said it wouldn't change anything
[Music]
[Applause]
WASC oh and the other musician started a
folk band which he insisted on calling
Wasco & Sons they had one song that
people really liked in a lot of other
thongs of people more or less tolerated
great for them what a [ __ ] what a Bop
what a Bop but it looks like there's
more members of the band that could be
there crap you solved five of Redwoods
problems with the increase in morale and
civic resources they were able to clear
the weeds from the road and fix the well
in broken hitch post there was even
enough left over to give the mayor's
office a new coat of paint and freshmen
refreshed the facade on the buttery
biscuit Oh ain't that lovely I wish I to
solve more problems I you told me you'd
all be dead there would be about the u14
of the reenactment scenarios at Fort
memoriam they still talk about you
remember when Mountain that muffler
fella came through here yeah he was
really good at this game you have any
more repair
all right with your help
Roy beans jellybean museum became the
talk of the town well first they have to
build a town nearby but once they did my
beans oh look that guys who weeing right
by the door there I'll look at that
whoo-whee
you left dirt water a nicer town than
you found it the streets were a little
safer and the people a little wealthier
and the children liked ice cream just a
little more the ice cream thing might
not have been because of you I guess oh
look at these happy people such happy
people as for you after your adventure
you settled in Frisco and bought a very
long very narrow house you fill it with
souvenirs of your exploits and starting
an antique Hatrack collection when you
left home you told Rufus you wanted to
help people over the course of your
adventure you helped 40 people
you weren't whistling Dixie when you
declared your intentions if you'd been
Catholic they definitely would have
sanded you if you had asked but you
wouldn't have asked because you wouldn't
want to be any trouble oh I'm so guys oh
I'm so frickin nice look at Bay in my
long narrow house
ah ah look at me but I could have done
more look at all those hats I didn't get
oh look about my spittoon and my
infinite bones where ever I would have
needed that but I didn't get everything
in 1906 all the remaining cows in the
West were simultaneously activated by
some kind of signal from hell they
thundered East forming a gigantic
single-minded herd led by the infernal
sadist Duke Bo victus the cow army
thundered east towards bear water the
Frick fortunately a gang a rodeo clown
swept in at the last minute and
slaughtered the herd just before Easter
water unfortunately all the town's folk
and dirt water had a hard time sleeping
for pretty much the rest of their lives
seriously it was a grisly sight 420
years later deep beneath your ground
ancient machines sadly stopped doing the
thing they were built to do it's
probably fine you and everybody no you
know are dead by then
most of humanity has moved to space
still though it's a shame about the
planet there were some cool bars there
oh no but I didn't finish the vibrate oh
I feel so bad no you said it wouldn't
change anything oh you said it wouldn't
change anything oh no oh you said it
wouldn't change anything
you said it wouldn't change anything you
said you said oh it feels too late now
always feels too late it feels too late
ah too late now I get it anymore you
might also enjoy our free boughs of bass
game the kingdom of loathing on the
Internet kingdom of loathing calm ah I
want to play that now
ah does this cutscene change when you do
different if you if I were to finish
everything now would it change okay
Frick that feels very final
oh man the adventure never ends huh
what am i doing oh the adventure never
ends but alas I suppose it's ended for
now but that doesn't mean it's over
because when I went to pax
West I'm at the developer and he gave me
a code for the horse DLC and this game
is absolutely amazing and there's more
laughs to be had but I will put it to
rest for now
and it will come back once I get all
this other stuff in order
Who am I kidding there's gonna be
another episode in like two days but I
want me to call this one the ending
because it felt like the ending the
ending quote question mark maybe but
it's good so thank you everybody so much
for watching this game an absolute
delight if you want to see me play
kingdom of loathing as well after I get
done with all the extra stuff in this
game because I'm gonna squeeze every
little bit of funny out of this because
like this game is a delight and a charm
and was fun the entire way through I
never had a boring moment in this entire
game even farming wasn't that bad and I
didn't have to farm that much this game
is a goddamn delight so thank you to
everybody who's watching thank you to
the developer and remember support the
developer there's a lot of different
ways to play this game you could play it
evil or you could go black hat you could
go hard mode you could be a bean slinger
you could do a ton of different things
so get the game support the developer I
want to see more stuff like this if any
game needs to be made it's more
this so thanks again everybody for
watching and as always I will see you in
the next video
[Music]